as we have explored in previous episodes
sufism is very strongly associated with
its artistic expressions and
particularly famous for its poetry we've
seen how great sufi personalities like
ibn arabi abu hassan ashri and atar
created lasting masterpieces of
literature that express the deepest
sentiments of islamic mysticism and
intimacy with god and another aspect of
this vast tradition of sufi poetry is
its multilingual nature
indeed especially from the late middle
ages forward sufi poetry started to be
written in various different languages
so vernacular languages that were
different from the more accepted
religious language of arabic for example
thus we not only see the beautiful
arabic poetry of people like the
aforementioned they've been arabi or ibn
fard but also at this time we have
masterpieces in persian from people like
rumi and jamie and we must not forget
that anatolia and the turkish-speaking
regions were also a place of great
flourishing when it comes to sufism at
this time and it is in this context that
we also find one of the most significant
sufi poets who have ever written in the
turkish language and just one of the
most famous sufi poets of all time
yunus emre
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
yunus emre is a kind of national hero in
turkey
it's said that most people there can
recite some lines from his poetry by
heart and he often comes to represent
the heights of turkish poetry and
literature
he also represents that classical era of
sufism when many of the greatest mystics
in history lived at basically around the
same time junos was a contemporary of
figures like rumi and thus took part in
this incredibly vibrant environment in
the last few years yunus has also seen
another surge in his popularity both in
turkey and elsewhere due to a successful
television series named after him and
based loosely on his life for those of
us interested in sufis and mansufi
poetry he is not a figure that we can
pass over and thus it is high time we do
an episode about him on this channel
junos lived in anatolia in what is today
turkey in the 13th and 14th centuries we
know very little about his life but the
common narrative is that he was born in
the early 1240s and died sometime in
1320 or 1321.
he thus lived in that very eventful
period when the mongols invaded and
ruled large portions of the islamic
world which had of course far reaching
consequences anatolia was ruled by these
mongol leaders during yunus's life and
the new situation of new muslim converts
from the east who had very little
knowledge of the religion's principles
probably played a role in his career as
a traveling missionary and kind of
minstrel because he never became the
center of a sufi order or necessarily
seen as a great saint in that way like
other figures such as rumi we don't have
any major hegeographies of his life so
all we have to rely on for his biography
are essentially details that he leaves
in his own poetry
undoubtedly yunus was a sufi a person
who was involved in the islamic
tradition of tasaw involving practices
aimed at purifying the soul and reaching
intimacy with god the sources we have
also suggest to many scholars that he
was connected with a so-called teke a
sufi lodge of initiated mystics under
the leadership of a sheikh or master
yunus's master appears to have been a
teacher by the name of tap duke emre as
eunice refers to this top duke in his
poetry as his own guide on the spiritual
path quote to the countries where we've
gone to those pure hearts filled with
affection we have spread tapatuk's inner
truth to the people praise be to god end
quote
as to what specific tariqah or sufi
order yunus belonged to that is
uncertain some have connected taptuk and
thus yunus to the bigtashi order which
was and has been one of the most
prominent in that region indeed the
founder of that order [ __ ] bektashveli
was an older contemporary of yunus and
some legendary stories even tell her how
the two met although eunice never
actually mentions hajibektash in his
poetry which is strange if the two
actually had a direct relationship like
that so this suggests to many scholars
that there wasn't a direct relationship
or connection between eunice and
hajibektash at least at this time but
this is a very uncertain matter someone
he does mention however is mevlana or in
other words the famous sufi poet and
master jalaladin rumi who was also an
older contemporary of eunice living in
the same region yunu seems to have great
reverence for this master and it seems
that the rumi served as a great
influence on the turkish poet it's also
possible that the two
poets met at some point but there is no
direct historical evidence for this
nonetheless yoona soon became a renowned
poet himself and it is said that he
traveled all around anatolia as a kind
of missionary he would use his
poetry to spread the message of islam
and educate people on the religions and
the the basic teachings of islam
through his beautiful poetry in the
vernacular turkish language he composed
a lot of poetry which was later
collected in a d1 which is essentially a
collection of a person's poetry
this d1 was only written down or
collected a few decades almost a century
actually after his death so it's
uncertain just how many of the poems
attributed to yunus can actually be
traced to the man himself the reason for
this late date of the diwan is probably
that the poems of eunus were composed
and transmitted orally he would travel
around the country and recite these
poems vocally probably with the
accompaniment of musical instruments we
thus almost get the picture of eunice as
a traveling minstrel singing devotional
songs as a way to spread the message of
islam and in particular that of the
sufism of his mentor taptuk emre indeed
yunus refers to himself as an ashik in
his poetry an ashik in anatolian culture
is a kind of traveling poet musician
that often plays on the instrument known
as the sars or balama while singing
poems often of a devotional sufi kind
these ashiks are still prominent in this
region today the word comes from the
arabic asha meaning a lover and in sufi
terms it is used to mean a lover of god
often synonymous with mystic so it is
possible that eunice is simply referring
to himself as a lover in these terms
without the connections that it had
later in anatolia but based on some of
the aspects of his life that we have
explored it is also possible that he
represents an early example of that
tradition of traveling singing poets and
regardless yunus poetry has come to play
a prominent role in the repertoire of
many ashiks to this very day so whether
or not he can be considered an ashak in
modern terms is uncertain but he
certainly plays an important role in
that general culture of aashik music and
poetry
from that time and until today
sufis in general have always played an
important role in spreading islam to
different regions of the world and the
time in which eunice lived was arguably
one in which this was very much needed
the invasion of the mongols and the
conversion of many of these mongols to
islam saw the need for someone like
yunus because now you had a bunch of new
people who had arrived from the east who
had just recently converted to islam but
had very little connection to that
religion and its teachings and didn't
have access to the
high seats of learning in places like
baghdad sometimes or
in arabia and so on and so someone like
eunice who could travel around and
spread the message of islam educate
people on this religion and its
teachings through his poetry and and the
sufi aspects of this religion was
something that was probably in high
demand aside from his diwan or
collection of poetry yunus also wrote a
work called the irisalet an nucia the
treatise of advice which he reportedly
finished in 1307 to 1308 an important
factor for dating his life this is a
really interesting treatise dealing more
with philosophical topics such as the
four elements the intellect and human
nature in general but to the majority of
people it is the catchy and simple yet
profound poetry that he is known for
so
what was this poetry about if you are
familiar with other examples of sufi
poetry particularly from this period a
lot of things will be familiar when you
read the verses of yunus in the most
general sense we can find two major
themes in his poetic works firstly the
basic principles and teachings of islam
his poetry is constantly in conversation
with the quran and hadith literature
referencing them explaining their
meanings and trying to educate on the
laws and practices of islam in different
ways secondarily though all of this is
also layered with the language and
expression of sufism and the mystical
way or path perhaps the most descriptive
term and central theme in all of his
poetry lies in the concept of love
he did refer to himself as an ashik or a
lover after all and all of his poetry is
dedicated to the expression of love just
like in the writings of rumi for example
love is the thing that is emphasized the
most in sufi terms this refers to the
mystics love for god often expressed
through metaphors of lover and beloved
of longing for one's beloved and wishing
to be united with him or her all of
sufism is infused with this love the
human being's love for god and god's
love for his creation and the human
being
this love for god can also then extend
to love of one's fellow man and creature
as an expression of god's being or
creative mercy
quote
love for you took me from myself it is
you i need you i burn for you both night
and day it is you i need you
if they should kill me and fling my
ashes to the sky my dust would cry there
it is you i need you
eunis emre is my name my fire increases
day by day in the two worlds my goal is
this it is you i need you
indeed in sufi poetry love is often
explained as a kind of metaphysical
principle it is love that holds the
universe together a love that is most
profoundly found in the love and
devotion of an intoxicated mystic for
god and a love which functions
essentially as the foundation of the
entire universe quote what can i tell
the lovers that is sweeter than the news
of love i will explain it one by one to
those who listen with love
before when there was no earth or sky
there was the foundation of love love is
very ancient eternal love brought about
everything there is
at the primal feast at the beginning of
time whoever saw the beloved's face his
soul was in love ask him for news of
love no matter what i try to liken love
to it doesn't work
in this world and the next what can take
love's place
it is entrusted to you guard well the
news of love do not sit just anywhere
and speak about love this is the rule
among the money changers they do not
show the jewels to those who don't know
their worth
now this poetry obviously doesn't work
as well in english translation as it
does in the original turkish but you can
still sort of get an idea of the melody
and rhyming and creativity that's going
on here he uses a lot of recurring
phrases like refrains and a lot of
repetitions in a very poetic way it's
really beautiful when you hear it even
though if you don't understand turkish
necessarily which i don't for example
you can still read or hear the original
poems in that language you can hear the
the melody and the rhyming and the
repetition it's really beautiful stuff
so this is how we should read eunice's
poetry as a lyrical expression of the
sufi concept of love essentially just
like for many other sufis god is seen
here as being deeply imminent
as the quran states quote we are closer
to them than their jugular vein and
quotes whichever way you turn there is
the face of god
the sufis took verses like these as
clear indications of god's immanence
in eunice's poetry god is present
everywhere quote wherever i look it is
he who appears before my eyes
i do not have comprehension or
discernment suitable to comprehend him
no matter how long i live freedom from
him is impossible for me
the prey caught in the trap is in the
hand of the hunter
to the wise breath is pleasant do not
ask about its characteristics
how can i explain his characteristics he
has no parallel he is without match
he promised everyone that tomorrow they
would see him my tomorrow is today the
almighty appeared here
eunice's total gazing is immersed in the
face of the beloved no place is left
where he is not present
every place appears filled with him
the true lover travels on the mystical
path to eventually achieve union with
god the most supreme experience of
intoxication
quote for the person who has achieved
union what is this pain and separation
for the person who sees the beloved up
close what is this remoteness he looked
at
it is necessary for the man who has
achieved union that he give up his
existence
this person who has achieved union who
is going along the road let's see what
his provisions are if you were a man of
union if you understood the veil over
the eye if you have seen the beloved
clearly renounce this existence
what is it after all nothing
this totally ineffable experience of
union with the divine
which is seen as one of the most
highest stages on the mystical path
has led to some of the most profound and
creative expressions of sufi poetry in
history
as we've seen in many other previous
episodes that we've talked about this
stuff
the sufis will play around with pronouns
using them in different ways and just
using the language that they are
employing in very creative ways to
express this
you know ultimately
inexpressible experience it is for
example this that is expressed when
eunice says quote it is not yunus saying
this it is itself that speaks
all of this has made eunice emre one of
the most celebrated poets certainly in
turkey and anatolia but really in the
whole world as we said in the beginning
his poetry can be recited by most people
in turkey even to this day the fact that
he wrote in the vernacular language
rather than in the more established
languages of religious expression such
as arabic or at that point persian is
probably one reason that he had such a
major impact indeed it is thought that
the poetry of
is a decisive factor in the very
development of the turkish language as
we know it today pretty impressive for a
wandering poet of the 14th century his
words can be heard in many popular folk
songs and at religious gatherings among
various groups in anatolia like in the
baktashi sufi order like for the alleys
for example his poetry is
recited and read
by many different groups religious
groups and and
groups of people he's one of the most
popular and well-known figures in
anatolian history his memory is kept
alive both through these contexts but
also in popular media such as in the tv
show dedicated to his life that aired a
few years ago it's a pretty decent show
actually all things consider that
includes many of the famous stories and
legends about jonas but stories that we
can't really confirm based on our
historical sources nonetheless any
understanding of sufism or sufi poetry
in particular is not complete without at
least some familiarity with the lover
yunus whose words reach us even today
with its playfulness and profound
messages
i'll see you next time
[Music]
foreign